devant sa vitrine entièrement brisée
alicea ne peut que constater les dégâts
avec amertume ils ont absolument tout
cassé j'ai plus de j'ai plus d'outils
j'ai plus rien ils ont tout volé
sèche-cheveux produits professionnels
mobilier qu'est-ce qu'il ne reste
quasiment plus rien je dis soir une
vingtaine des métiers s'introduit dans
ce salon de coiffure à Macon et le pays
en quelques minutes seulement je me sens
complètement démunie je sais pas comment
je vais faire
je sais que ça va être long long parce
que comment ça présent les démarches
d'indemnisation avant le passage d'un
expert cette jeune coiffeuse de 28 ans
doit effectuer un inventaire mais les
premières nouvelles ne sont pas vraiment
rassurantes j'y crois pas j'y crois pas
du tout je me dis que
enfin j'aurais rien de plus que ces
petits 12000 euros même si c'est une
grosse somme mais sur les dégâts c'est
rien quoi 12000 euros c'est rien ça paye
à peine mais vitrines les dégradations
des vitrines j'ai tout à refaire là
juste à côté les locaux de cette
assureur ont subi le même sort ils ont
complètement cassé les pages c'est par
ici qu'ils sont rentrés et qu'ils ont
que saccagé absolument toute mon agence
ici aussi les hommes me tiens ont tout
cassé volé du matériel informatique les
dommages sont importants c'est plusieurs
milliers d'euros dizaines de milliers
d'euros je pense avec les vitrines mais
j'en sais pas trop plus pour l'instant
parce que j'attends les chiffrages
Christophe Kai n'est pas inquiet pour
l'indemnisation de ses locaux mais il
gère une dizaine de dossiers de
commerces vandalisés et suivant les
contrats les professionnels peuvent
avoir de mauvaises surprises celles et
ceux qui n'auraient pas souscrit de
perdre d'exploitation peuvent se
retrouver dans cette forme de difficulté
lourde qui est même difficulté qui peut
entraîner la cessation d'activité
d'accord ensuite sur les options c'est
le vandalisme extérieur où il peut y
avoir discussion dans certains cas
l'assureur rappelle que les assurés
peuvent mobiliser l'aide de l'État ce
dernier étant civilement responsable en
cas de dégâts commis par violence ou par
des attroupements armés ou non